welcome to the future of privacy and
security track at the microsoft research
summit
i'm robert sim research manager in the
privacy and ai group in microsoft
research and i'll be your host for the
day
more than ever we depend on systems and
services to provide us with critical
infrastructure and to enable ai enhanced
assistance
in recent years we've witnessed a crisis
of confidence in the integrity of our
election systems and we've observed an
emerging array of attacks against ai
systems that can compromise user privacy
at this particular moment in time it's
crucial that we can trust the systems we
build to be secure and to protect users
privacy and customer confidentiality
at microsoft trust is a cornerstone of
our commitments to our customers
over the years we've invested heavily in
ensuring that the security and
confidentiality of customer data is
safeguarded
microsoft is the birthplace of
differential privacy and has pioneered
efforts in developing secure computation
solutions such as homomorphic encryption
we're continuing to push the boundaries
of what's possible through next
generation investments in privacy
preserving machine learning secure
computation and ai assisted threat
detection
in this session we'll explore three
themes that aim to address emerging
challenges in the security and privacy
space
our first theme will focus on privacy
preserving machine learning
this research area seeks to understand
the privacy risks that might arise when
artificially intelligent systems are
deployed and how we can mitigate them
we will learn from professor don song
from the university of california
berkeley about the technologies needed
for responsible data use and how they
work can work towards a responsible data
economy
professor kobe nissim from georgetown
university will explore the gaps between
legal and technical approaches to
privacy and microsoft principal
researcher melissa chase will share
progress on research and privacy
preserving machine learning at microsoft
later in the track microsoft senior
researcher shruti topol will host a
panel discussion with our speakers and
other prominent privacy researchers to
discuss the future of privacy and ai
the panel consisting of microsoft
researchers and collaborators will
discuss two questions among others how
do security and privacy technologies
address emerging challenges related to
data sovereignty
and what are the important emerging and
long term directions for privacy
preserving machine learning research
our second theme will focus on election
integrity our democratic institutions
are faced with increasing demands for
transparency and electoral processes
how can we be certain that election
tallies have reflected all eligible
ballots and how can individual citizens
verify that their ballots have been
correctly counted
in this session we will explore
technologies that enable voters to
confirm the correct counting of their
boats and the embodiment of these
technologies in election guard a free
open source tool kit designed to help
implement verifiable voting systems
we'll start with a tutorial from
microsoft senior principal cryptographer
josh benilo describing the technology
how it works and how others can
contribute
we'll then hear from professor dan
wallach at rice university who has
developed a course module for using
computer security classes
following these presentations we will
host a live q a session with dr benilo
and professor wallock to address your
questions about these technologies and
opportunities
finally our third theme will explore
secure parsing for untrusted input to
prevent mistreatment of malformed input
one of the most common causes of
security bugs where attackers can gain
control of software system through
carefully crafted input
in this theme we'll hear from darpa
program manager and dartmouth university
professor sergey bradis about secure
parsers for binary document formats such
as pdf through the darpa safe docs
project
microsoft principal research software
development engineer tahina ramanandro
will discuss implementing secure parsers
for communication protocols using
everparse a framework for generating
provably secure parsers and formatters
used to improve the security of critical
code bases at microsoft which can be
used not only for new protocols but also
to provide hardened parsers for still
widely used protocols
microsoft principal researcher asim
rostogi will provide a demonstration of
everparse
trust is a critical component of
microsoft's relationships with
individuals businesses and governments
to open this track we'll invite
microsoft technical fellow jim cleveland
to share with us how microsoft is
approaching problems and privacy and
security in our product groups such as
microsoft office and windows
in particular jim will share the
challenges in privacy-preserving machine
learning and how rising to those
challenges will create opportunities for
microsoft to continue to build its trust
with its customers by leading in
security and privacy
even as we encounter new and emerging
threats that target system integrity and
user privacy we will see throughout this
track how microsoft and our partners are
addressing key problems in privacy and
security and how we can build trust and
confidence empowering every person and
every organization on the planet to
achieve more